hey what's up guys this is dark souls 2
PvP gameplay and it's everything we know
so far so what you'll see in this video
are some of the best Dark Souls to PvP
clips that I could find and all of them
are courtesy of peeve peterson who's
actually one of my favorite streamers
over on twitch TV and i know it's gonna
be hard guys but hopefully you can focus
on what i'm sayin with these awesome
clips going on in the background and i
say that but even right now i'm getting
distracted by the fact that he's dual
wielding a [ __ ] great axe and a great
sword yeah i'm gonna talk about that
later so if you were really lucky a
couple of months ago you might have had
the chance to play some Dark Souls 2 and
this video is an aggregation of most of
the knowledge that came out of that test
and there's a bunch of really
interesting stuff but it is worth
mentioning that the developer wanted
this to be a network stress test not a
beta meant for balancing the game or
anything like that so don't get me wrong
I believe this footage gives us an
insight into the final product but bear
in mind that a lot is subject to change
so without further ado let's get into
the good stuff first off a lot of stats
have changed and a few new ones have
been added so what do these mean for PvP
the most interesting new stat that's
been added is agility the description
states that agility is an attribute
governing swiftness of movement it says
that it boosts speed of evasion blocking
and other actions every time I've played
Dark Souls 2 this has been my favorite
attribute to upgrade without it your
character will feel much more sluggish
it's unknown exactly how much you should
have before your character starts to
feel tight to control like it would in
the first game but it's definitely
important to throw a few points into
this attribute and I'm just going out
there and saying that you definitely
need a few points in this attribute to
be able to play the game well it's worth
noting that we're not entirely sure
whether its agility or soul level that
changes the way your character feels
with agility you definitely raise your
shield faster and it can improve the
speed of your role and maybe even the
distance of your role it seems to
increase the speed of most actions
including drinking Estus and using items
but the thing is that I'm not a hundred
percent sure of everything it affects
right now there's a lot of little things
I'm gonna say like it improves the
turning circle on your carrot
it might affect run speed it might
affect the speed of your parry
invincibility frames these are things
that we really have to test and figure
out for certain when we get our hands on
a final game just know that if dark
souls2 pvp is going to be anything like
Dark Souls PvP then agility is going to
be a big deal because in Dark Souls PvP
movement was always king lighter all
characters were pretty much essential in
PvP in the first game and while heavy
characters seem to be more viable in
Dark Souls 2 I reckon having better
movement will always be a core component
of PvP in a Souls game anyway going down
the stab list we see a division of some
stats and minor additions to other's
vitality has been renamed to vigor an
attribute that determines your HP
vitality is now an attribute that
determines your maximum equipment load
you can hold which used to be a part of
endurance
now endurance only determines your
overall stamina so what we're seeing
here basically is a division of stats
that allows more fine-tuning of the
characters you have honestly I feel like
increasing equipment load might be a
little bit too weak as a stat especially
when you consider something like agility
which improves the speed of your rolls
as well but I'm sure these stats will be
really important in some builds moving
on let's talk about resistance your
favorite stat in the first game
resistance now governs defense in way
more areas than before it allows you to
block with greater efficiency and it
also means that you have a reduced
chance of being guard broken and in Dark
Souls 2 being guard broken is a much
bigger deal and I'll get into that in a
moment but someone in the beta actually
pumped resistance really high and they
noticed that arrows and projectiles were
doing literally no damage also small
dagger attacks had their damage reduced
it was almost as if it increased some
sort of threshold where damage actually
affects you resistance actually sounds
amazing this time around it seems like
it boosts the effectiveness of your
armor as well so much so that you can
just shrug off small attacks like
they're nothing strength and dexterity
have experienced changes with strength
weapons having a greater emphasis on
breaking guards and dexterity weapons
boosting poison and bleed effects so
think about this for a second it means
that strength index
don't just increase the damage of a
weapon anymore instead they boost the
effectiveness of a strength or dexterity
playstyle and I'll try explain what I
mean by this when you use strength
weapons breaking people's guards will be
an important thing because when you get
hit while blocking you'll lose stamina
lose all of your stamina and you get
guard broken that's what it's like in
Dark Souls now when you get guard broken
in Dark Souls 2 you go into a reportable
animation so you have your guide broken
and you'll go into an animation where
they do a huge amount of damage similar
to a parry riposte or a back step this
is awesome it means that strength build
characters now have a way to play
according to these new mechanics if you
have a huge weapon you'll be trying to
crush your opponent's guard so your
enemy goes into the animation you're
saying on the screen right now the more
strength you have the more easily you'll
do that and the more resistance you have
the more effective they're blocking will
be I can't wait to see how competitive
play looks with these mechanics on the
flip side it looks like dexterity users
will have more emphasis on bleed and
poison effects so in Dark Souls you got
bled out if you got hit with a weapon
too many times in quick succession
losing a huge percentage of health if
this occurs bleed effects go through
shields
so now strength and dexterity playstyles
have a way to get around people who hide
behind their shields both playstyle seem
really viable - you'll see in the
footage how strength weapons seem to
have faster swings and more knock back
effects this time around and how
dexterity weapons are brilliant when
dual wielded and brilliant when they
used appropriately I assume there will
be more dexterity weapons that have
bleed effects or maybe some that have
poison effects maybe even upgrade paths
that allow these effects to come into
play so one thing you might have picked
up from what I'm saying about Dark Souls
2 it just feels like every playstyle is
going to be viable and I'm gonna talk
about casters now so casters are looking
to be way better in PvP since they have
a huge variety of spells this time
around but that's not all so they have
more a oe attacks and they have more
attacks that can be used more
effectively in melee but in addition to
this the achievement step now increases
the speed of casting in addition to the
amount of slots you have meaning it will
be much harder to dodge spells and
Sol's to intelligence and faith stats
remain more or less the same except now
they boost certain types of damage and
defense intelligence boosts magic and
fire attack and defense meaning there's
been a merging of pyromancy into the
spellcasters arsenal faith boosts
lightning and dark attacks and defense
whether this applies to the damage of
melee weapons remains to be seen that
I'd say it's likely perhaps fire and
lightning weapons will now scale with
faith and intelligence like a cult or
enchanted weapons did previously overall
these stats sound like really good
additions to the game but once the game
comes out though we can see other PvP
landscape changes because of them but I
think it's shaping up really nicely so
far so in the beta people did what
people do and they jump to conclusions
and one of those conclusions was that
stun locking would be a huge issue and I
think it's way too early to say that at
this stage and that's not just because
the game is in beta but also because
there were many mechanics that we might
not have had time to get our head around
yet now poise still exists in the game
but the armor sets we were given didn't
really stop us getting stun locked at
all be it from small fast weapons or
larger slow weapons now I just don't
think this will be a problem it would be
a glaring oversight for from to miss
this so there will be mechanics in place
that stop you getting stun locked cave
Peterson has a few ideas in his video
which you should watch after this by the
way namely that boosting agility might
allow you to raise your shield between
weapon swings and stop the stun lock and
that also poise will help you deal with
the stun locks from smaller faster
weapons now this makes a lot of sense
and it would be a really balanced way
for the developers to deal with it you
know small weapons gets topped by high
poise and slow strong weapons gets
topped by raising your shield in the
middle of a swing and he even
demonstrates his shield being raised
between zweihander swings here
effectively stopping the stun lock from
taking place he also notes that there
might be diminished damage on successive
hits so diminished returns at this point
in his video peeve talks about how
distance from the weapon might actually
affect damage meaning movement' would be
way more important than ever and the
skill cap for
he would be really high if this was a
major factor and here we see shield bash
is actually doing damage and not only
that but I've seen clips of people
reposting with the shield which makes me
think that shields could be an effective
weapon in your main hand which would be
really interesting the lag in the beta
wasn't bad at all I had no trouble
connecting to people and my interaction
with others was honestly better than in
Dark Souls it seems like the hosted
servers are definitely doing their job
compared to the peer-to-peer connections
we had before in Dark Souls the kick has
been replaced by a sort of backhand move
where you run forward a few steps then
smack your opponent haven't found much
footage of this taking place but
apparently it's a really great way of
breaking someone's guard and once again
we see game design being built around
stopping people from hiding behind their
shields which is awesome the next thing
is parrying and back steps and back
stabs especially you remember were a big
deal in PvP in the first game
backstabbing is preceded in Dark Souls 2
by a smacked they're back with your hand
before performing the back step they
seem a little bit more difficult to pull
off because it's actually harder to get
behind your opponent with the new
movement system and it also seems like
you can roll through the initialization
of a backstab so that you won't be
affected by it in various clips you see
someone initiating the backstab that
failing to pull it off you can also take
damage while back stabbing someone
meaning back steps are a less viable way
of dealing with two enemies at once the
parry system has changed too there's now
a delay before the parry animation takes
place and enemies who have been parried
for flat on their back before being
reposted parrying shouldn't have a huge
change in PvP because you still have to
account for lag a little bit and peeve
demonstrates how you can parry someone
if someone's mashing the r-1 button just
like in Dark Souls 1 if someone's
mashing our one you can parry in between
their swings and you'll actually be able
to pull off a parity stopping their spam
and I've got one more topic for you guys
after you listen to this you'll be
pretty much set for everything Dark
Souls 2 in terms of PvP invading and
summoning what's changed the biggest
change in my opinion is that now you can
be invaded while Undead and now I know
some people will say or vari I don't
want to deal with being invaded even
though it's a core component of a Souls
game but I still want to summon people
help me and to those people you have to
say get good because at least it means
PvP will be way more active in Dark
Souls 2 remember all those invasion
failed messages you got in the first
game finally we can invade the players
who don't want to be invaded and that's
glorious some people will complain about
this and I am being a bit too harsh but
I don't really think you should complain
being invaded is a part of the game and
you can't really complain if it's
balanced
if PvP isn't balanced then you have the
grounds to complain but Fromme has said
that there will be ways to defend
yourself from being invaded so hopefully
there is something for the people that
complain and if there isn't just play
offline and you'll still get a good Dark
Souls experience speaking of ways to
defend yourself from being invaded
covenants there are a few new PvP
covenants and one of them is called the
way of blue where you were literally
tasked with defending people from
invaders where a covenant ring and
you'll be summoned into people's worlds
to defend them from red phantoms or
maybe you'll have people drawn into
yours to defend you when you're invaded
by red phantom and the red phantom
covenant is called the brotherhood of
blood and they act similar to how
darkwraiths did in the previous game
players can also summon white phantoms
just like in Dark Souls 1 but now there
is the addition of a white phantom timer
where white phantoms can only stay in a
world for a limited amount of time
before being kicked out and I assume
this is an attempt to stop people
steamrolling the game and
defeating all the bosses with summon
help because you know you beat a few
bosses with summoned help and all of a
sudden you're too far in the game and it
does take away from the experience a
little knowing that you can have this
easy way out if you're having trouble
with the game so the final question with
all this is how well is it balanced with
invaders and summoned help having
timeless and honestly I think it's too
early to say but you should try to
decide on your own based on this
information
invaders invade with 75% health they can
use Estes now but for invaders Estes
regenerates their health really slowly
almost like a life gem this is unless
you're summoned with a red summoned
soapstone for a dual type thing where
you're on completely even footing so if
you think invaders feel a bit
underpowered from what I said earlier
really you just have to use the enemies
to your advantage and also take into the
account that the person you're invading
also has reduced health also now you're
summoned help has a time limit meaning
they will have to chase down an invader
in order to be of any real help during
their time slot so you can't just wait
for the invader to come to you honestly
it's just hard to know how this will all
be balanced until we actual play it but
those are the facts right there make of
them what you will and that's me done
for the day guys I think I covered
everything if you liked the footage from
this video then please check out
previous video is really nice of him to
give it to me to use but overall thanks
for watching feel free to like comment
and subscribe
and I'll talk to you guys in the next
one later
hey everyone and welcome to a new series
where I challenge your knowledge of Dark
Souls 2 if you've been subscribed to my
channel for a while then you should
already know some of these awesome
changes to the game or maybe you'll at
least learn some new ones as usual let's
play the game with the like and the
dislike button if you learn something
new in this video leave a like if you
get 5 out of 5 and know everything well
done and feel free